لنا الحاكم الروسي لمدينه سيفاستوبول
احباط هجوم صاروخي قرب مطار بالمدينه ياتي
هذا في سياق تدفيف القوات الاوكرانيه
استهدافها شبه جزيره القرم بطائرات مسيره
وصواريخ وتاكيدها تدمير انظمه دفاع جوي
ومنشات بحريه في شبه الجزيره بالتزامن مع
استمرار الهجوم الاوكراني المعاكس واحتدام
القتال على جبهات المواجهه الاخرى مع
روسيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كندا خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي
الاهداف التي تسعى لتحقيقها بالاتجاه
لتكثيف هجماتها على شبه جزيره القرم في
الفتره الاخيره وما فرص نجاحها في تحقيق
هذه الاهداف
وما خيارات موسكو للتعامل مع تركيز القوه
الاوكرانيه على استهداف القرنفض استمرار
الهجوم العدسي الاوكراني على جبهات القتال
الاخرى
وكيف سينعكس تكثيف اوكرانيا هجماتها على
القرن على مسار الحرب الروسيه عليها وما
حدود المسؤوليه التي تحملها موسكو للغرب
عن هذه الهجمات
[موسيقى]
في خضم احتدام القتال على مختلف جبهات
المواجهه بين روسيا واوكرانيا وفي سياق
تحذيرات روسيه من احتمال اندلاع مواجهه
شامله مع حلف الناتو تواصلت الهجمات
الاوكرانيه على شبه جزيره القرم اذا اعلن
الحاكم الروسي لمدينه
احباط هجوم صاروخيا قرب احد مطاراتها هجوم
الثلاثاء على القرم التي تستضيف المقر
العامه للاصول الروسي ياتي في سياق ضربات
مكثفه بدات القوات الاوكرانيه توجيهها نحو
اهداف في شبه الجزيره مؤخرا مستخدمه
المسيرات والصواريخ بل وحتى للهجمات
الالكترونيه حسبما اعلنت سلطات القرم
المعينه من روسيا
ومع بروز تصريحات منسوبه لمسؤولين روس
ذكرت ان اوكرانيا ربما تكون استخدمت
صواريخ غربيه في هجماتها على القرم تقول
تقارير ان كياف تسعى بهجماتها على شبه
الجزيره لارباك دفاعات روسيا بمهاجمه خطوط
امدادها ومراكز قيادتها بعيدا عن خطوط
المواجهه المباشره
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع عن معنى منك يا سارهي
المحلل السياسي والامني ومن موسكو جريجوري
تروفى
الخبير المختص في سياسه الخارجيه والدفاع
والامن كما ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكريه
والاستراتيجي ابدا مع ضيفنا من كييف السيد
لماذا
بدات اوكرانيا بتكثيف هجماتها بهذا الشكل
وباسلحه ثقيله جدا على اهداف في شبه جزيره
القرم لم تكن مستهدفه من قبل
مسائكم طيب وشكرا على هذه الدعوه هذا
مرتبط
اولا ان اوكرانيا تقوم بتصعيد قدراتها
وانتصاراتها وتقوم بضربات في العمق الروسي
وفي عمق الاراضي المحتله الاوكرانيه بما
فيها القرم
واذا ما كانت في بدايه هذه الحرب ما كانت
اوكرانيا لتستطيع ان تستخدم المسيرات او
الصواريخ بعيده المدى الان اصبحت اوكرانيا
تنتج هذه الاسلحه وتستخدمها بفعاليه كما
حصلت اوكرانيا على صواريخ بعيده المدى من
شركائها فالمنطق في هذه الضربات يعتمد على
ان
المهام العسكريه الموضوعه يجب ان تنفذ لان
القرم هي قاعده عسكريه روسيه كبيره جدا
يحتفظ فيها على الذخيره والمعدات العسكريه
والجنود
وحتى لا تستخدم هذه القدرات وهذه الذخائر
في الجبهات تقوم اوكرانيا بتوجيه ضربات
على القرم وتدمر كل هذه المنشات في القرن
الشيء الثاني هو ان روسيا تستخدم
القوات الجويه حتى
تقوم بافشال وابطاء الهجمات المضاده
الاوكرانيه
وروسيا تعتقد ان هذا الشيء فعال وناجح لان
لديها الكثير من الطائرات المقاتله
واوكرانيا الان في هذا المجال ممكن ان
نقول انها تخسر امام روسيا لانها ليس
لديها هذه القدرات ذلك من المهم ان نقول
هنا ان علينا ان نقوم بضربات التجمع
القدرات الجويه الروسيه لان هذه القدرات
تنطلق من القرن هذه الطائرات تنطرق من
القرم وتقصف المنشات المدنيه
والقوات العسكريه ايضا
هنا باختصار شديد هل لتجثيف الهجمات على
القرم هل لتتثثيف الهجمات على القرن علاقه
بالتباطؤ الهجوم المضاد الاوكراني او حتى
عدم تحقيقه اهدافا كما كان مامولا من قبل
باختصار
كما قلت كل هذا مرتبط بالطبع لان القرم هي
قاعده للحفاظ على الذخيره والطائرات التي
تستخدم من روسيا على الجبهات لذلك يجب ان
تدمر هذه القدرات في القرم حتى تنجح او
تزيد سرعات الهجمات المضاده
طيب
ضيفنا من موسكو سيدي جريوري ما هي خيارات
موسكو للتعامل مع هذا المستجد الميداني
وهو استهداف
الاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود استهداف
شبه جزيره القرن استهداف جسر القرم مع
العلم ان روسيا منذ عام
2014 تعتبر القرن جزءا منها
نعم اريد ان اقول على الفور ان في الداخل
وفي المجتمع الروسي المعلومات عن الهجمات
في القرن قليله جدا
لان لذلك المجتمع هادئ تماما اما بشكل عام
اوكرانيا
وشركائها الغربيين يعملوا
بالطريق الاقل
مضادات
يعلمون ان الهجمات على القرن اسهل وقد
يصلوا الى نجاحات سياسيه وعسكريه اسرع اما
بالنسبه لعام 2014 انا كخبير اريد ان اقول
انه بعد عام 2014 وبعد اوضاع القرم نبهت
ان القرم ليست نهايه كل المشاكل بل بدايه
المشاكل لروسيا الفيدراليه ولكن القليلين
من سمع هذه الوجهه من النظر وعدا عن ذلك
هناك شيء مهم واستراتيجي مهم جدا هناك
توقعات ان
اوكرانيا قدمت الفرصه لروسيا
الفرفصه ليدخل
الى القرم حيث كان هناك المسلحين الروم
ولكن ليس هذا نقاشنا سيد جريجوري عفوا
ليس هذا نقاشا الان نقاشنا حول الاستهداف
الاوكراني المستجد لشبه جزيره القرم التي
تعتبرها روسيا ارضا روسيه وبالتالي كانت
قد هددت
اذا ما تعرض العمق الروسي ها هي القرن
تتعرض الان
لهجمات هل لنا ان نفهم لماذا ليست هناك
معلومات في روسيا ولا حتى في القرن عن هذه
الهجمات ولا تصل معلومات الى الداخل عن
تلك الهجمات الاوكرانيه
اشخاص وهم المراسلين العسكريين والمؤثرين
الروس وهم في الفتره والاونه الاخيره
يتساءلون كثيرا لماذا لا تقوم روسيا بردود
صارمه على هذه الهجمات كما كانت تتوعد
وعدا عن ذلك لماذا لهذه الضربات مكانا في
الواقع ضربات بالمسيرات وليس هذا وحسب
بصواريخ والمجتمع يتمنى ان تقوم روسيا
الفيدراليه بردود صارمه اي هجمات ضد
المهاجمين حتى لا تتكرر هذه الضربات ولكن
للاسف للاسف الكبير نرى ان هذه الهجمات
تستمر
وقد يكون احد وسائل الرد على هذه الهجمات
هو ان المجتمع
الروسي بشكل عام لا يرى هذا العزم والقوه
الروسيه ولا يفهم خطوره الاوضاع اللواء
فايز الدويري
كيف تقرا هذه الهجمات وهل تعتقد بانها
يمكن ان تحقق اهدافها على الاقل الاهداف
التي تحدث بها ضيفنا من كييف
يعني اولا اذا عدنا الى التصريحات
السياسيه الهدف الاوكراني الحديث عن
استعاده السيطره على شبه جزيره القرم
واعتقد هذا الهدف من الصعب بمكان تحقيقه
على الاقل في المدى المنظور ضمن المعطيات
الحاليه اذا ما هو الهدف الاخر او الادنى
هذا ينبع من اهميه شبه جزيره القرن كقاعده
خلفيه
تزود اله الحرب بالجندي بالمعدات والسلاح
والذخائر وكل انواع الامداد وبالتالي هي
طريق او الشريان الحيوي الرئيسي لهذا
السبب لابد من فرض حالي من عدم الامن عدم
الاستقرار الحاق الاضرار بمنظومات الامداد
العملياتي والاداريه لان ذلك سينعكس سلبا
على القوات الرو التي تقاتل على خط على
جبهه تزيد عن 900 كيلو متر وبالتالي اتوقع
ان
الاوكرانيين سيستمر في تنفيذ هذه الهجمات
حتى وان استطاعت روسيا ان تسقط 90% من
الطائرات المسيره او الصواريخ لماذا لانه
وصول 10%
واصابه هدف حيوي او استراتيجي سيكون له
تداعياته
النفسيه والمعنويه والماديه وهذا ما حدث
في هجوم يوم الجمعه تم اسقاط خمسه صواريخ
وصل الصاروخ السادس كان التصريحات
الاوكرانيين تتحدث عن مقتل قائد الاسطول
حتى ثبت العكس اذا دعني اقول الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لشبه جزيره القرن في بعدها
العسكري تحديدا وحول الموضوع الذي نتحدث
به يفر ض على القاعده العسكري المقابل ان
يواصل عمليه الاستهداف وهنا اتحدث من
ضروره من منظور عسكري بحث طيب سيد سيرجي
سبق لي اوكرانيا ان وعدت وهذه بتصريحات
اوكرانيه واضحه ان الاسلحه الغربيه التي
تزود بها لن يستخدم بها العمق لم يستخدم
لم تستخدم في ضرب العمق الروسي الان
هل تستخدم الاسلحه الغربيه فعلا في ضرب
شبه جزيره القرم على اعتبار ان الغرب لا
يعترف بها ارضا روسيه هل الاسلحه
المستخدمه الان هي اسلحه غربيه لضرب شبه
جزيره القرم
الضربات على مركز اسطول البحر الاسود
استخدمت صواريخ
او سكلب وهي صواريخ
متماثله قدمت من بريطانيا لاوكرانيا ومن
فرنسا وهذا شيء واضح حتى من الفيديوهات
ومن شكل الصاروخ المربع ولا نرى اي ردود
عكس سلبيه من بريطانيا او فرنسا بالنسبه
لاستخدام هذه الصواريخ هذا يعني ان شركاء
ان يعتقدوا ان هذا شيء مسموح به ان يكون
وهذا شيء هام جدا لانه بعد هذه الضربات
شركائنا لم يروا في هذا اي رد فعل حقيقي
من اطرف الروسي في الزمن السابق كان
الشركاء يخشون التصعيد اذا ما كان هناك
ضربات على القرم او على الاراضي الروسيه
فقد تقوم القوات الروسيه
برد فعل تصعيدي لهذا النزاع ولكن الان
شركائنا ردوا انهم ليس عليهم ان يخشون هذا
وان اكثر ما قد تقوم به روسيا هو
تصعيد بالكلام من قبل مدفيدف التي سوف
يقوم بالتهديدات لدول الناتو وكان روسيا
سوف تحارب دول الناتو وهذا شيء مضحك
للجميع لان روسيا سوف تخسر فورا روسيا
تخسر الحرب في اوكرانيا فكيف سوف يحارب
دول النيتو يعني لم تعد لم يعد الغرب يخشى
اي ردود روسيه لا ادري ان كان الامر
سيستمر على هذا المنوال سيد لانه تعليقا
وكما ذكرت تعليقا على مد الغرب كياف
بالاسلحه المتقدمه واخرها دبابات ابرز ام
واحد الامريكيه المتطوره والمزوده بذخائر
مضاده للدروع قال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي دي متر ان الخيارات امام موسكو
تتضاءل ومنها خيار المواجهه المباشره مع
الناتو الذي تحول الى كتله فاشيه شبيهه
بمحور هتلر على حد تعبيره واضافها ان
روسيا بحاله جاهزيه وانها تدرك ان حجم
الخسائر في مواجهه كهذه سيكون اكبر مما تم
تسجيله في عام 19
هنا انتقل الى ضيفي من موسكو السيد
جريجوري ما جدي هذا التهديد هل فعلا موسكو
التي لا ترد على هجمات على شبه جزيره
القرن
ستدخل بمواجهه مباشره مع الناتو هل هذا
الامر
منطقي وواقعي بالفعل
انا اعتقد انه في هذه العمليات الجاريه
المعقده هناك الحرب النفسيه العسكريه
اعتقد ان في هذه الظروف من الافضل ان
يتكلموا اقل ويقوموا بعمل اكثر لذلك عندما
يكون الحديث اكثر بكثير في هذه الظروف
ولكن من وجه الطرف المراقبين الاعمال
القليله فهذا يرخص هذه الكلمات ومن وجهه
نظر الضغط النفسيه
وفي اي حرب يجب ان تقوم بالاعمال ثم تبدا
تتحدث ومن الافضل ان تقوم باعمال دون حديث
وانت ساكت لذلك الحديث الفارغ
والتهديدات الفارغه المباشره هذا ما ينظر
له بطريقه بسيطه جدا من وجهه النظر
المعاكسه تماما بل هذا يؤدي لقيام الطرف
الاخر باعمال اكثر حده وهذا ما تقوم به
اوكرانيا باستخدام المزيد والمزيد من
الاسلحه وتقوم برفع حراره درجه حراره
النزاع ولذلك الغرب ينظر لاعمال موسكو
ويقوم باعمال باكثر حريه ولا
لا استطيع ان اتخيل لاي مستوى قد يصل
الدعم الغربي لاوكرانيا ولكننا نرى ان هذه
الاعمال مستمره من الدول الغربيه بحريه
الان
وصلت لاوكرانيا المعدات الاكثر جديه
وخطوره وتطور بل واوكرانيا لا تقول انها
هي من تنتج هذه الاسلحه المتطوره اذا
الاوضاع تتطور بسرعه ومن المستحيل ايقافها
ايقافها يعني الكلمه الاخيره هي هي
المفتاح سيد جريجوري من المستحيل ايقافها
هل
نريد ان نفهم منك
بانه ليست هناك خيارات مواجهه فعليه يعني
ليس امام روسيا الا ان تقبل بالامر الواقع
هذا استمرار استهداف شبه جزيره القرم
محاوله اسقاط
صواريخ
والسكوت على كل
المد الغربي لاوكرانيا لم يعد لدى موسكو
اي وسائل للمواجهه باختصار
روسيا بالطبع لا تستقبل الواقع كما هو ولا
تتقبله ان روسيا تتعامل مع هذا النزاع
بالكلمات بدل ان تقوم باعمال محدده هناك
الكثير من الاعلانات والحديث من
المحللين الروس ويتحدثون عن السلاح الذي
لا اريد ان اذكره هنا لانه من وجهه نظر
حتى الخبراء الروس هي الوسيله الوحيده
التي ممكن ان تعيد الطرف الاخر والطرف
الغربي للعقل والعقلانيه وتخفف ضغط الغرب
على القرب ولكنني لا اعتقد انه استخدام
السلاح الاخير والضغط الاخير
من الطرف الروسي سوف يوقف هذه الاوضاع في
هذا النزاع وروسيا تفهم هذا الجيده في
الاخير تقصد عفوا تقصد
لفقت لنفهم منك
تقصد النووي هذا هو الضغط الاخير
باختصار
في الاعلام الرسمي من الخبراء الروسي
يتحدثوا عن استخدام الاسلحه النوويه ولكن
انا كخبير لست من الذين يؤمنون بهذه
الكلمات والتهديدات لانه اذا قاموا
باستخدام اي شيء من هذه الاسلحه بما فيها
النوويه هذا شيء لا يتحدث عنه واذا يتحدث
عنه وهذا يعني انه لن يتم استخدام
هل الاستراتيجيه الاوكرانيه حاليا
مجديه من وجهه نظر عسكريه وتؤثر في ساحه
المعركه
يعني الان هناك
يعني عنده توصيفنا لما يجري في مناطق
العمليات نجد في الصفحه الاولى المعارك
التقليديه
تاريخيا وهي معارك القوات المتقابله هناك
اخفاقات لا اقول اخفاقات هناك عدم القدره
على تحقيق انجازات وهذه الانجازات تترجم
في المعارك التقليديه
بسيطره على اهداف لا يوجد هناك سيطره على
اراضي حاسمه او اراضي تعبويه او اراضي ذات
قيمه حيويه من كلا الجانبين الهجوم المضاد
بدا منذ حزيران نعم حقق انجازات ما يقارب
240 كم مربع لكنه لم يسيطر على اهداف
حاسمه تسهل العمليات اللاحقه يقابل ذلك
هناك الحديث عن منطقه ليمان واطراف
الايمان والهجوم الروسي لم يحقق انجازات
لهذا تم اللجوء الى الصفحه الاخرى او الى
المسار الموازي وتم استخدام الصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره وغير ذلك
للابقاء على اله الحرب
دائره ولكن هذا مؤشر خطير جدا وهو بدايه
الدخول في نفق حرب الاستنزاف وحرب
الاستنزاف مضني للطرفين ولكن
الانجازات اللحظيه والانيه والمتتاليه
ستفضي الى نتائج عملياتيه من يحقق هذه
الانجازات على شبه يومي يستطيع ان يتحدث
بعد اسابيع واشهر عن تغير في المقاربه
العسكريه الشامله ولكن لا نستطيع ان نحكم
على ذلك من خلال يوم ويومين واسبوع
واسبوعين الان ماذا على اوكرانيا ان تفعل
على اوكرانيا ان تحاول ان تصريحات
السياسيين بما يتماشى مع الميدان الحديث
عن القرن شبه جزيره القرم والسيطره عليها
هل يعلم الجميع ان القوات الاوكرانيه تبعد
125 كيلو متر لم تصل تكمك وهي على بعد 25
كيلومتر لم تصل ميلوتوبل وهي على بعد
خمسين كيلو متر اذا دعني اقول هذه الحرب
قد تمتد لسنوات وسنوات والقادر على الصبر
وادامه اداه اداه المعركه من حيث
الامدادات العمليه في ولوجستيه والذي
سيكسب في النهايه ولكن بعد انهاك كلا
القوتين بما فيها من يقف خلف اوكرانيا
شكرا جزيلا لك الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من عمان وشكرا لضيفنا من
موسكو غريغوري ميتشوك الخبير المختص في
السياسه الخارجيه والدفاع والامن كذلك
نشكر ضيفنا من كييف سير هيبوظلوف
المحلل السياسي والامنيه
انتهت حلقتنا شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]